if you're still playing batman arkham  knight Warner Brothers and Rocksteady  are still supporting you crime fighter  challenge pack number six is available  now on PC and it hits ps4 and xbox one  on January 26th the newest pack revisits  iconic Batman locations like Wayne Manor  and the Batcave places we visited in  Arkham Asylum and Arkham City these maps  were selected by members of the Arkham  Knight community the dlc was actually  called the community challenge pack at  first altogether there are six maps to  play through and everyone can download  the new batman incorporated skin for  free when the pack launches after a  rough start on PC Arkham Knight has  received a ton of content if even more  gets announced will tell you all about  it on gamespot now if you'll excuse me I  still have a bunch of Riddler trophies I  need to collect